alors je crois qu'il ya un élément
important au niveau des pme qui est la
commande publique quelques chiffres en
premier lieu la commande publique
aujourd'hui c'est 401 milliards d'euros
rien que les achats publics c'est 200
milliards tout ce qui est services
alimentaires fourniture de repas 7,19
milliards d'euros ces dix mille repas
servis chaque jour or les pme n'ont
quasiment pas accès à ces marchés aussi
on sait aujourd'hui qu'à peu près 20 %
des pme arrive à accéder au marché à la
commande publique or c'est un vrai
levier de croissance pour nos
entreprises et là les régions doivent
pouvoir répondre à la demande des
entreprises doivent pouvoir faire en
sorte que les entreprises accèdent à la
commande publique on sait que les
socialistes ne réussissent pas du tout
un exemple dont on vient d'avoir les
éléments il y a quelques jours la coop
21 le gouvernement avait indiqué sur les
3000 emplois prévus pour la cap 21 dans
quelques jours ce sera essentiellement
des emplois qui seront issues de la
seine saint denis du 93 or les chers
amis on a les résultats aujourd'hui sur
les 38 prestataire retenu pour la coop
21 ces quatre pme du 93 c'est à dire un
petit peu plus de 10% de véritablement
là encore les socialistes des paroles
mais derrière les actions complètement
différente il faut que les régions
apportent un soutien à la fois aux
acheteurs et à la fois aux pme au niveau
des acheteurs il faut responsabilité
responsabiliser les acheteurs sur les
achats il faut qu'on arrive à se sortir
du moins mieux disant par rapport au
moins dix ans véritablement aussi que
les acheteurs arrivent à faire en sorte
de ne pas toujours retenir les offres
les plus basses ils en ont la
possibilité
mais ils ne le font pas toujours établir
aussi au niveau des acheteurs un système
de sourçage c'est à dire avant de lancer
les appels d'offres faire un état des
lieux de l'offre disponible sur le
territoire faire en sorte aussi que les
acheteurs mettent dans leurs appels
d'offres des clauses sociales des
clauses environnementales faire aussi
peut être au niveau des régions que les
jour prévoit dans leur appel d'offres
une part réservée aux entreprises
innovantes on pourrait imaginer qu'une
part soit réservé aux entreprises
innovantes sur un ratio qui pourrait
être de 2 4% avec une évolution ou alors
à véritablement faire en sorte de
responsabiliser les acheteurs sur
l'impact au niveau local ça peut être
fait sur tout ce qui est un marché de
fourniture de repas ça peut être fait à
tous niveaux au niveau des entreprises
aussi il ya un vrai travail à faire
parce qu'aujourd'hui les entreprises
sont démobilisés par rapport aux appels
aux appels d'offres il faut leur
redonner une ambition il faut leur
redonner une envie et pour ça leur
apporter un soutien les régions peuvent
être des acteurs pour mettre en place
des mutualisations des services de
soutien pour que les entreprises
puissent répondre aux appels d'offres il
faut bien évidemment simplifiée aussi
aujourd'hui c'est quand même très
difficile et les entreprises ont une
épée de damoclès au dessus d'elle par
rapport à tout ce qui est le délit de
favoritisme faut sortir de ça et aider
les entreprises à se prémunir certes
mais à ne pas avoir que ne pas être
finalement que dans un climat de
défiance mais également être dans un
climat de confiance et je terminerai en
disant que ceux ci aura encore plus
d'importance demain qu'aujourd'hui parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons 22 régions
demain 13 ça veut dire que les appels
d'offres seront encore plus gros
quasiment ils seront du double donc les
pme ont encore plus de difficultés
finalement accéder à ces appels d'offres
parce que les marchés seront doublés au
niveau des régions donc les régions
doivent être un soutien on sait que le
gouvernement socialiste n'y arrive pas
on l'a vu avec la coop la cap 21 et donc
je sais que les candidats à l'ensemble
de nos candidats prennent ça à un hacker
et là il ya un véritable effet de levier
pour les pme en tout cas moi j'y crois
je sais que nos candidats y croit